quand vous appelez pour intervenir
est-ce que vous avez mesuré tout de
suite l'ampleur de l'opération ou ou pas
du tout à ce que vous comme comment ça
s'est passé
oui en mesure à l'intervention au nombre
d'appels qu'on reçoit d'accord
l'intensité de cet appel mais aussi
grâce aux images qu'on perçoit
aujourd'hui les moyens modernes nous
permet d'avoir instantanément un certain
nombre d'image au centre opérationnel
donc on à la salle des appels au centre
opérationnel on a cette vision sur ce
déclenché cet incendie qui commence à
prendre et rapidement quand les engins
se présente on perçoit ce qu'on a
travaillé ce pourquoi on s'entraîne ce
qui est difficile et ce qui existe assez
régulièrement
malheureusement dans les immeubles
haussmanniens c'est-à-dire un feu sous
combles un feu sous toit qui se
développe assez vite parce que le toit
sur les immeubles haussmanniens et
encore plus sur cet édifice atypiques
sont très grands et grands volumes et
charpente qui ne sont pas recoupé donc
ils ne permettent pas d'arrêter le feu
et c'est normal puisque la structure est
ainsi est ainsi fait et on constate
assez vite que ce feu est poussé par un
vent d'est
donc on mesure ce feu qui a pris
vraisemblement autour de la flèche qui
se propage très vite dans ces grands
volumes qui sont habillés par cette
équipée d'une forêt d'arbres un kiki et
la charpente
donc faut savoir que les gaz chauds se
propage avant que les flammes nes et les
gars chaud entraîne sa lune tout seul et
font naître ces flammes ces flammes sont
poussées sont entretenus par ce vent
d'est encore une fois et on craint assez
rapidement pour l'instant de l'édifice
c'est ça la question se pose après cette
phase de sidération qu'elle est est ce
que quand on est quand on est quand on
est pompier quand on est voilà vous êtes
lieutenant-colonel quand on nous appelle
là pour c'est ce qu'on dit on fonce
direct est ce qu'on se dit on a déjà un
plomb dans la tête ce qu'on réunit ses
hommes ont dit voilà on va on va faire
ça on va faire ou bien on vit on y va
direct on va voir sur place quand voilà
qu'est ce qu'on se dit à ce moment là
bas effectivement alors fait ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que les pompiers de
paris sont couvre quatre départements
8500 hommes et femmes est sûr c'est qu'à
département il ya peu près 80 caserne 80
caserne qui s'appuie mutuellement c'est
une grande famille on serre les coudes
donc par rapport à un édifice
notre dame et bien les moyens sont
prévus pour tout départ de feu c'est à
dire que les moyens ne vont pas être les
mêmes que pour un feu d'appartement bien
voilà et les casernes qui sont
limitrophes connaissent parfaitement
laquelle la cathédrale savait exactement
où sont les escaliers savent exactement
où se trouve la colonne sèche c'est à
dire la colonne qui permettra de
s'alimenter de brancher nos tuyaux et
d'envoyer l'eau aux bonnes au bon niveau
c'est ce qui a été fait au début les
équipes s'engagent par là les escaliers
s'engage par l'extérieur donc en fait
les premières caserne connaissent très
bien les lieux des exercices sont fait
très régulièrement
non seulement pour appréhender ce type
de sinistre mais aussi pour évacuer les
oeuvres on sait par exemple quelques
oeuvres
il fallait évacuer dans le trésor et
donc quelle oeuvre mérite t elle tout ça
ça doit se faire très vite donc vous
vous saviez déjà comment ça se passe
parce que les séries qu'il faut agir
très vite il faut c'est un plan
voilà il ya un plan établi ouais chacun
connaît son rôle et par rapport à ce
plan on s'y entraînent régulièrement
c'est ça donc vous aviez subi vous avez
fait des entraînements à notre-dame ou
pas du tout oui 2018 fait deux
entraînements
d'accord c'est ce qu'on avait vu parce
qu'elle veut un reportage qui avait été
fait d'ailleurs sur france 2 on voyait
voilà que vous voilà les des pompiers
s'entraîner au cas où notre dame
prendrait feu oui il ya eu deux
entraînements effectivement pour évacuer
les oeuvres mais en ce qui ce qui m'a
aidé être souligné mais mon camarade
jérôme demay qui est le chef de sang du
centre de secours de poissy disait très
justement sur d'autres supports de
de vos collègues qu'il connaissait il
s'est présenté le premier ça tombait
bien parce qu'il connaissait
parfaitement les lieux ainsi que ses
hommes et femmes d'accord une femme dans
son équipage et ils sont engagés
d'emblée par les escaliers ils savaient
très bien qu'au bout de l'escalier une
petite porte
il savait très bien où se brancher ils
savaient très bien après la porte ce
qu'ils allaient trouver
voilà donc la connaissance des lieux en
amont fait que les gestes réflexes pour
lesquels on s'entraîne au quotidien sont
posés d'une manière assez rapide entre
l'appel et la présentation sur les lieux
il ya moins de dix minutes
c'est un moins de dix minutes ainsi
c'est fou vaut mieux habiter à frei que
dans l'oeil alors alors justesse car
moment vous êtes dit on pourra pas
sauver notre dame est ce qu'à un moment
vous êtes dit ça ou est-ce que vous n'y
pensiez même pas vous ai dit on va on va
faire le nécessaire et on va essayer d'y
arriver coûte que coûte mais ce qu'à un
moment vous avez doute est ce que vous
aviez un moment on pourra pas le faire
moi il faut savoir dans notre
organisation il ya ceux qui s'engagent
d'emblée parce qu'ils connaissent les
lieux et puis il ya ceux qui prennent du
recul
d'accord un conte un peu plus
d'expérience et c'est une cellule
commandement et coordonnées qui est
assez éprouvée parce qu'elle a subi un
certain nombre de choses qui prend du
recul et qui estime par celle des moyens
techniques vous avez un drone qui
permettait de voir la progression de cet
incendie
il ya un retour aussi des chefs de
secteurs qui étaient tout au long de
tout autour de cet édifice et qui
rendait un certain nombre d'informations
à ce chef des opérations qui lui a été
amené à prendre des décisions assez
rapidement parce que il a constaté
qu'effectivement ce feu allait se
propager à l'ensemble de la toiture qu'
il était poussé par un vent d'est très
puissant avec nos moyens à l'extérieur
ou à l'intérieur ne suffirait pas et
puis face au potentiel effondrement de
la flèche ce qui s'est avéré
oui mais la première décision a été de
retirer a demandé aux équipes qui
étaient engagés à l'intérieur de
l'édifice de sortir c'est la première
chose mais et c'est le bon choix parce
qu'il s'agit n'a trop perdu d'hommes
sept dernières années
comment on a permis deux camarades en
janvier il s'agissait de préserver nos
camarades d'armes
ça c'était la première de la première
décision en fait de retirer l'attaqué
par l'extérieur
la deux le deuxième choix ça a été de se
dire où est ce qu'on peut l'arrêter ce
feu pour éviter qu'ils ne touchent les
beffrois bien sûr alors effectivement
le feu étant violent 800 degrés environ
poussé par le vent encore une fois nos
moyens hydrauliques parfois sont pas
forcément adaptées peut-être un peu
pauvre il faut donc s'approcher du feu
et le choix était fait ça c'est la
deuxième décision de contenir le feu
avant les beffrois notamment au niveau
du de la tour nord là où le feu
commençait à gagner
la charpente qui soutient les cloches
alors il ya une prise de risque aïe
elle est mesurée elle est partagée avec
ceux qui vont s'engager avec ceux qui
décident et puis une fois que l est
évidente
il faut y aller les gars on y va
exactement alors est ce que est ce que
vous avez senti d' est ce que vous avez
eu les avez eu peur pour vos hommes est
ce que vous avez un moment un moment on
se dit qu est ce qu on a aussi le chef
de l'état au téléphone ou le ministre de
l'intérieur qui vous dit qu'est ce qui
se passe on en est où est ce qu'on va
réussir à sauver notre dame s'il est
question aussi qu'on se pose les
téléspectateurs sur se pose qui yvonne
on imagine comme dans un film on se dit
est ce que le flux emmanuel macron vous
appelez vous a dit qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous êtes potes le porte parole
des pompiers de paris
il sait c'est dû à quoi où on en est
pensez que vous allez y arriver parce
que vous l'avez eue alors pour répondre
à votre première question sur la peur
mais de s'engager
notre devise c'est sauver ou périr
maintien ça veut tout dire
ça veut pas dire que on y va pour périr
ça veut dire qu'on mesure le risque est
qu'on l'affrontent d'une manière
consentie alors habituellement c'est
pour sauver son prochain clairement là
c'est pour sauvegarder des biens et on
sait on sait que notre dame
c'est un bien qui nous est cher et donc
il fallait y aller donc c'est un risque
assumé c'est ainsi partager et puis on
ne va pas seul
c'est une c'est la force du collectif
des pompiers de pareilles c'est des
frères d'armes qui s'engage
on se connaît c'est une grande famille
et on y va ensemble donc quand on y va
ensemble on est plus fort et puis part
pour l'échangé d'informations la prise
de décision bien introduit qu'à eu des
pointes situation fait régulièrement aux
différentes autorités
mais comme vous l'a dit le secrétaire
d'état lors en une aide qu'on avait vu
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
mais laissons faire les pompiers voilà
donc il ya une grande confiance de
l'état
il ya une grande cohésion
des services de l'état pour faire en
sorte que les pompiers interviennent le
plus facilement possible évidemment le
jura galles est notre chef
oui avant ces décisions là les a exposés
aux autorités quant à six risques
calculés quant au fait d' envoyé des
équipes dans les beffrois pour arrêter
le feu en sachant très bien que le
risque zéro n'existe pas que la
charpente pouvait continuer à brûler que
les cloches pouvait s'effondrer et que
l'édifice pouvait peut-être stabilité
déstabiliser complètement alors on sait
qu'il ya un de vos collègues qui a été
blessé on se demande comment il va
aujourd'hui
oui il a été très blessé très légèrement
c'est encore un coup de chaud d'accord
donc ça va donc être là bien là très
bien mais alors est-ce que c'est ce que
vous faites plein d'intervention est ce
que c'est une intervention qui va rester
gravé dans votre mémoire ce que c'est
l'intervention qui restera dans votre
carrière
celle dont vous vous souviendrez le plus
pour ma part j'en suis sûr
c'est super j'en suis sûr parce que
c'est une adresse à laquelle j'aurais
pas et même présenter quand les pompiers
arrivent et partent sur intervention ils
ont ordre de départ ils savent qu'ils
vont intervenir avec tel est l engin est
donc on part et quand on arrive sur laon
par pau une adresse et on se présente à
l'adresse en disant voilà je suis arrivé
voilà l'action que je mène bon et quand
on se déplace vers notre dame qu'on
aperçoit ce feu qui gagne en intensité
et qu'on arrive devant cette façade
cette belle façade oui il ya une
sidération
et puis c'est un mauvais rêve au début
et on se dit mais qu'est ce qu'on va
pouvoir faire
vous êtes fiers de ce que vous avez fait
aujourd'hui à poils à trois jours après
où il a dit j'aimerais faire un boulot
de parole je vais je vais je vais déjà
je parle de tous les pompiers y avait
une file heures et je suis fier de mes
camarades je suis fier de mes camarades
ouais je suis fier de mes frères d'armes
qui qui sont engagés parce qu'il parce
qu'il donne chaque jour un sens à leur
vie tout simplement qu'ils sont engagés
avec eux avec intrépidité avec courage
abnégation avec altruisme ça les nôtres
on a trois mots qui guident notre action
c'est l'altruisme l'efficience parce que
c'est un métier et la discrétion
alors on ne peut que 5
l'ine devant notre dame bien sûr et pour
autant quand il faut y aller faut y
aller c'est pour ça qu'on s'entraîne
tous les jours
oui je suis fier de cette cette
communauté d'hommes et de femmes qui
savent s'engager pour un bien qui les
dépasse merci merci connaissent un
témoignage très fort